Aurora
ice users in anime are often cool and
compose characters who can manipulate
frozen water in various ways from blood
chilling techniques to creating massive
glaciers let's dive into some awesome
moments when ice uses an anime flexed on
their opponents
[Music]
with the strongest ice-type zambakto and
the audacity to ask his opponent's name
before defeating them he unleashes are
never seen before ability that puts the
third Espada at his Mercy everything the
snow touches freezes into a flower and
haribel becomes nothing more than a
confectionary Tower Of Ice And if it
wasn't for Wonder wise Hari belt would
have been killed by her fracion the hype
and the intensity of this scene was
amazing especially considering that
hitsugaya is probably one of the most
light characters in Bleach his strength
in spiritual pressure that was even
noticed by other captains in Espada and
manga readers should know that this
isn't even his greatest feat yet that's
something for a future video
foreign
this is one of the coldest scenes in
anime from a relatively slept upon
series
[Music]
one of the most memorable scenes in
gekkai Sensen and Beyond is the one
where Stephen A starface unleashes his
power of needles of absolute zero
against a group of enemies who betrayed
him this scene showcases that it's
Stephen's call and ruthless personality
along with his blood technique that
makes him a terrifying ice user he can
control the direction and speed of the
needles with his mind and can also make
them explode into shards of ice it shows
that Stephen isn't someone to be messed
with and that he has a strong sense of
justice and loyalty a master manipulator
and a powerful combatant in his own
right Stephen being able to deduce the
Ambush and catch his enemies off guard
by using the needles shows that if
someone is monologuing at you while
being held at gunpoint then the game's
already over
you can't have a list of ice users
without the nagama wielding stripper
from Fairy Tale
foreign
battles in fairy tales final season was
the clash between gray and invel the
winter general of zeref's army the fight
wasn't only a test of strength and Magic
but also psychological warfare that
pushed greater his limits with his
emotions Frozen and having to choose
between his love for Juvia and his duty
to stop zeref gray had to unleash his
true potential and show his resolve the
fight pushes Gray's character
development and emphasizes the
importance of his role in the story it
also showcased his impressive ice magic
skills and his rivalry with invel who
was a formidable opponent giving gray a
power up in the final Arc by defeating
one of the most powerful ice users in
fairy tale a bonus benefit is that this
finally gave progress to the great and
dubious ship that we've seen and
suffered through all throughout the
series
next is an underrated remake of a golden
anime horohoro from the 2021 version of
Shaman King
horohoro's fight against Jackson and
gondo from Team young is more
spectacular than ever in this version of
the anime porohoro is a shaman from the
ainu tribe who can control ice with his
Spirit Ally gororo he uses his ice
powers to create various weapons and
structures such as snowboards icicles
Shields and ramps you can also
manipulate the temperature and moisture
in the air to create snow storms and
blizzards using his new oversoul nippopo
gauntlets horohoro blasted a hole
through Jackson's spirit and froze
avocados from a snowboard loving idiot
to a badass member of Team Ren porohoro
made quick work of two Elite Buddhist
shamans and gained their recognition to
receive one of the five grand Elemental
Spirits it seems the beating two of
their Elite shamans that can go to hell
and back is a very effective resume to
be eligible to receive one of the
greatest power-ups in the world of
Shaman King
[Music]
now before we continue let's thank
today's sponsor mad tail Idol RPG let me
just say outright that this is one intro
interesting RPG taking some of the most
beloved fairy tales that we've grown up
with and adding a new Edge to them
players can go on adventures with dark
and twisted versions of their fairy tale
favorites taking on some intense and
strategic battles with the dream team as
well as collecting some amazing rewards
strategy is key here in this Idol RPG
it's a game that ought to give you busy
bodies a lot of fun mad tail Idol RPG is
set to be online on July the 12th and
pre-registration is ongoing this is by
far the best way to get into the game
with some frankly insane
pre-registration bonuses I'm talking
about a lot of free items the S partner
mirror queen and a lot more bonuses that
will keep snowballing the more people
pre-register let's hit that Milestone
together eh oh and the kicker a
pre-summon event that's available for
all of us who pre-register and you can
do this twice a day too all of this is
only available from July the 1st to July
the 11th pre-summond twice a day mirror
Queen on my way while we're at it you
can also check out all these cool
summons waiting for you being available
in both Android and iOS as well as
having support for over nine language
you'd be sure to meet some great players
from across the globe drawing forces and
save mad tail Fairyland with them while
collecting characters and making them
the strongest versions possible with
these symbiotic weapons to add your
inventory if you're up for something
more challenging how about trying out
some battles against those friends you
meet madtale is the idol RPG set to take
the mobile gaming World by storm July
12th is the launch day and you don't
want to miss it pre-register and get a
head start in joining in the fun
once again lots of thanks to Mad tail
idle RPG for sponsoring this video links
in the description another ice user that
will most definitely show up here is
dodoroki and his fight against Cerro in
my hero Academia
calling in this one a fight would be
giving the tape man too much credit
since this is a one-sided battle that we
can't see going any other way than
dodoroki winning even when Cerro took
the initiative and attacked first by
immobilizing Todoroki the son of
endeavor was just too strong he was able
to freeze Sarah and half of the arena
with a single move leaving everyone's
speechless and stunned the ice that
formed was so big it even eclipsed
outside the arena even Eraserhead who's
usually Carmen collected was left
stunned by that single move the fight
was just another stepping stone for
Todoroki and an outlet to express his
anger and frustration after being
confronted by his father
thank you moving to the next entry
before we all freeze to death Miyuki
uses niflheim on the Invaders during the
first season of irregular at Magic High
School
foreign
sister can be a monster by herself since
she's mostly portrayed as the cliched
loving sister to the main protagonist in
this power fantasy anime but this moment
in particular showed us that she's no
joke and has no qualms about killing
people too for the crime of trying to
stab her beloved brother in the back
Miyuki completely freezes the attacker
in his place and his allies watching
horror the other dozen or so Vaders are
next as they stand in place and watch as
ice gathers from below their feet slowly
crawling up their bodies this spell
Miyuki used is able to produce dry ice
and even liquid nitrogen from the air
the technique ignores heat and
appearance using magic to uniformly cool
down all the objects within a set area
so no matter if it's an object or a
person and no matter how many there are
as long as they're in the Spell's
vicinity they will get Frozen this
simple scene perfectly encapsulates just
how far Miyuki will go to protect her
brother and that she does have the power
to do it but also uses said power in a
no-nonsense and straightforward approach
that will either leave her victims a
statue of ice or a burning crisp
quite a different tone from the rest on
this list now seeing Puck turn into the
Beast of the end is one of the most
memorable and horrifying moments in the
first season of re zero
[Music]
now if you're a fan of re zero you
probably remember the shocking scene
where pack Reveals His True Form as the
Beast of the end a gigantic cat-like
creature with golden eyes and immense
power the horror of this moment is hard
to describe as Puck unleashes his wrath
on the world after Amelia's death
freezing everything in his path and
destroying anyone who opposes him Park's
transformation isn't only terrifying but
it's also heartbreaking as he abandons
his cute and playful personality and
becomes a ruthless monster who only
cares about fulfilling his contract with
Amelia the build up to the reveal was
great since Subaru dies two times from
freezing to death before we get to see
what caused it his first death in the
underground tunnel teases Punk being
responsible when we hear his voice as
Subaru shatters into pieces the second
death is where his true form is finally
shown as a hulking Beast that Looms from
afar we can only watch as Subaru freezes
from the blizzard caused by Puck and his
head is blown over by the Winds of ice
the credits role accompanied by a
melancholic Orchestra to show just how
hopeless of a death this was with a
blizzard engulfing everything until all
we can see is Snow White
[Music]
[Applause]
the most badass ice user to ever exist
in anime RG and his fight against the
straw hat show just how dangerous the
Marine Admiral is
[Music]
angry and tired of our Gigi's taunting
game Robin used her devil fruit
abilities to break him into pieces
against usop's wishes but in one of the
greatest flexes of any ice user in any
form of media he came back from being
broke into pieces and breathed on the
grass to create an ice saber which just
goes to show that the limitations of his
devil fruit might as well be his
imagination if he was as brutal as a guy
knew one piece would have ended years
ago the fight left a lasting impression
on both sides and foreshadowed future
events that would shake the world all
Gigi wasn't even serious but he easily
overpowered Luffy Zorro and Sanji and
almost killed Robin with his freezing
touch the only reason he spared them was
because of his past connection with
Robin's friend Jaguar D Sol who was also
a former Marine and if that isn't a flex
then I don't know what is two Flexes in
one
[Music]
possibly one of the most powerful feeds
done by an ice user as death freezing
Literal time versus susano in Agame ga
Kill is one you shouldn't Miss
she possesses a powerful Daegu called
demons extract that allows her to
manipulate ice and mold it from nothing
due to her ego and immense mental
willpower she was able to withstand the
daegu's overwhelming insanity and obtain
its abilities she uses it to create
icicles freeze people to death and more
a testament to asda's power is that she
was actually capable of creating her own
trump card techniques for her Daegu
something no other Dagu user has ever
been able to accomplish as the Daegu
themselves had such functions built into
them by their creators in the first
place the most powerful of a trump cards
is mahab Dharma which allows her to
freeze time and gives her a moment to
make a move during its effect it's
during the fight with susano and
nigender that she first revealed this
ability nagenda activated susanu's
ultimate ability magadama manifestation
in an attempt to create a diversion for
Knight raid to escape intending to
sacrifice both herself and susano but as
death freezes time and just casually
walks up to susano before stabbing him
and shattering his Daegu into pieces
while this didn't end susano's life when
allow him to sacrifice himself so that
the other night raid members could
Escape that showed just how overpowered
as death was her only problem was a
massive ego that underestimated her
opponents and her one-sided Obsession
for Tatsumi s death may have been a
crazy woman but that still won't stop
many people from wanting to be stepped
on by her and that may be her greatest
Flex yet
and those are my picks for moments when
ice users flexed on their opponents
there are so many more cool characters
and other anime that I'm bound to have
missed out let me know what you think in
the comments section below leave a like
and thank you so much again for watching
this video
foreign